سفير ايران لدى الامم المتحده يتهم
اسرائيل بالمسؤوليه عن هجوم طائره مسيره
في اصفهان
في تقييم عسكري قاتم يحذر من ان الوضع على
الجبهه في شرق اوكرانيا يزداد خطوره
الفلبين تمنح واشنطن حق الوصول لقواعدها
ووسط يقول ان بلاده ستعالج الانشطه
المزعزعه للاستقرار
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير قال مبعوث ايران لدى الامم
المتحده امير سعيد ارفاني ان التحقيقات
الاوليه تشير الى ان اسرائيل كانت مسؤوله
عن هجوم بطائره من دون طيار على منشاه
عسكريه في اصفهان واضاف لوكاله اسنا شبه
الرسميه الايرانيه ان العمل الذي تقوم به
اسرائيل يتعارض مع القانون الدولي
وفي شان الايرانيين اخر اظهر مقطع فيديو
ترديد اهالي اصفهان لشعار وراء كل قتيل
الف شخص وذلك ضمن الاحتجاجات ضد النظام
الايراني
[موسيقى]
ونزل كذلك اهالي فولاد شهر في اصفهان في
الشوارع للاحتجاج مرددين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اما في الشان الاوكراني واخر التطورات
الميدانيه قال الرئيس الاوكراني
ان الوضع على الخطوط الاماميه شرقي البلاد
يزداد الصعوبه مع تكثيف روسيا هجومها وسط
تقدم متزايد نحو بخموت قائلا ان الروسي
يحاولون تحقيق مكاسب للتباهي بها وذلك
بالذكرى الاولى للحرب في الرابع والعشرين
من فبراير الجري بدورها افادت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني انا مليار بان القوات
الروسيه تحاول السيطره على اراض بالقرب من
مدينه ليمان والتي تعد مركزا لوجستيا
استراتيجيا واوضحت ايضا ان الجيش الروسي
يقوم بمحاولات قويه لاختراق الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه مشيره الى مواصلتهم الهجوم في
باخموت
بنكييف ينضم الينا الصحفي محمد البابا
اهلا بك معنا محمد اذا ما اخر التطورات
الميدانيه التي تشهدها ارض المعارك حيث
انت
نعم بالفعل ولكن بدايه يعني القصف
الصاروخي الذي طالما مدينه
سقط ضحيتين بشكل رسمي بينما يعني مصادر
غير رسميه ان عدد الضحايا ارتفع الى اربعه
قتله وثمانيه جرحه وايضا يعني خضع اكثر من
30 شخصا لعمليات اسعاف اوليه بعد قصف يعني
عنيف طال مدينه وقد تم يعني تدمير مبنى
بشكل كامل القوات الروسيه ايضا بالقرب
يعني على بعد 30 او 40 كيلومتر من مدينه
كان هناك قصف على مدينه قسطنطينه ايضا
واستهدفت بعض المباني
السكنيه والتي تعتبر شبه فارغه بعد عمليه
اجراء السكان التي تقوم بها القوات
الاوكرانيه في تلك المنطقه الجيش الروسي
يواصل التقدم باتجاه وهي مدينه تعتبر
قاعده عسكريه
لمدفعيه الاوكرانيه التي تقوم بقصف مدافع
ومراكز تجمع القوات الروسيه في قطاع
الجمباز الروسي ايضا يحاول يعني اطباق
الحصار حول مدينه والاتفاق حول مدينه ضخمه
حيث تجري اشتباكات عنيفه في المناطق
المجاوره لباخمت القوات الروسيه تضع كل
ثقلها في هذا المحور للتقدم ودفع القوات
الاوكرانيه للتراجع من مدينه
ايضا مدينه تتعرض لهجوم كبير القوات
الروسيه ايضا تحاول التقدم باتجاه مدينه
سيفرك ولابعاد القوات الاوكرانيه وبذلك
تطبق الحصار بشكل كامل او بشكل كماشه يعني
ثقيله على القوات الاوكرانيه في باخ محور
ريما ايضا بدا يشهد تحركات للقوات الروسيه
التي حشدت حوالي سبعه الى ثمانيه الاف
جندي على هذا المحور وتحاول التقدم
لاستعاده بعض المواقع التي خسيرتها القوات
الروسيه قبل ثلاثه اشهر او اربعه اشهر في
محور اليمن في محور جيفولوجيا ايضا هناك
هجوم على مدينه تحاول قوات الروسيه الوصول
الى مداخل تلك البلده وتصطدم بالدفاعات
الايرانيه التي الجيش الاوكراني قام بنصب
ست او سبع خطوط دفاعيه وشكل وحدات دفاعيه
في تلك المنطقه لوقف تقدم القوات الروسيه
الرئيسكي اكد خلال كلمته بالامس على صعوبه
العمليات وين كثافه الهجوم التي تقوم به
القوات الروسيه في قطاع الطمباس خلال
الساعات يعني 24 الماضيه
بيان هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
محمد هذا التقدم الروسي لشيء ما ربما
استراتيجيه مختلفه ربما اسلحه معينه
يستخدمونها ليحرزوا هذا التقدم المفاجئ
ربما في هذا القطاع او في بخموت تحديدا
نعم بالفعل ولكن يعني المفارقه هي الحشد
العسكري الكبير والضخم يعني اكثر من 150
الى 200 الف جندي روسي والذين خضعوا
للتعبئه اضافه الى عدد كبير حوالي 60 الى
70 الف من مجموعات وهم يعني كما يتداول في
وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه من
النزلاء السجون في روسيا تم تجميعهم
جميعهم وضمهم الى مجموعات وزن الخطا
للتدريبات في بيلاروسيا وفي روسيا ويشنون
هجوم كبير وضخم في قطاع الدمبر هناك
محاولات واستراتيجيه من الجيش الروسي
محاوله تقديم التقدم واحتلال معظم
المساحات الجغرافيه لمقاطعتي مقاطعتي
وايضا لذلك الهجوم الكبير الروسي بدا في
تلك المنطقه القوات الاوكرانيه تضعف من
حده الهجوم الروسي ولكن كما قال الرئيس
الاوكراني يعني هناك بعض التقدم وهناك
صعوبه في العمليات العسكريه في تلك
المنطقه شكرا لك الصحفي محمد البابا
يزور اكثر من عشره مسؤولين اوروبيين كبار
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف للقاء اعضاء في
الحكومه الاوكرانيه عشيه قمه بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي واوكرانيا ومن المقرر ان يلتقي
الرئيس الاوكراني مع رئيس المجلس الاوروبي
ورئيسه المفوضيه ارسال غدا الجمعه للبحث
في الدعم المالي والعسكري لاوكرانيا
مسيرتان بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعدتها في الدفاع عن نفسها
في الوقت الذي تستعد لمواجهه هجوم روسي
جديد متوقع قبيل الربيع المقبل المزيد مع
الزميله ليال
مسيرتان بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعده الاخيره بالدفاع عن
نفسها في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لهجوم روسي
متوقع قبيل الربيع المقبل فوفقا الامريكيه
شركه جنرال اتوميكس الامريكيه التي تعتبر
من اكبر الشركات للصناعات العسكريه في
العالم عرضت على وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بيع كل طائرتين من دون طيار من طراز ام
كيوناين ريبار مقابل دولار واحد الصفقه
ستتطلب من كياف انفاق حوالي عشره ملايين
دولار لاعاده وشحن الطائرات الى اوكرانيا
وحوالي ثمانيه ملايين دولار الى لكل عام
لصيانه هذه الطائرات من دون طبعا طيار
القديمه والتي لا يتم استخدامها حاليا في
اوكرانيا العرض يشمل ايضا محطه تحكم ارضيه
لتشغيل الطائرات من دون طيار في اي مكان
على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا لرساله
الصحيفه الامريكيه انها طلعت عليها مسيرات
هي ليست مسلحه ولكن يمكن حملها في حقيبه
على الظهر وتستخدم لتصطدم بالاهداف يبلغ
طول جناحي ريبار حوالي 66 قدما ويمكن
تصليحها كما يمكنها ايضا ان تطير لاكثر من
اربعه وعشرين ساعه البيت الابيض الذي
سيتعين عليه الموافقه على صفقه البيع رفضت
التعليق على الامر حتى الان واشنطن كانت
قد قدمت في العام الماضي اكثر من 700
طائره من دون طيار اصغر الى اوكرانيا بما
في ذلك طائرات من دون طيار تكتيكيه من
طراز سويتش بليت
السلطات الامنيه الهولنديه اعلنت ان
قراصنه الكترونيين موالينا لروسيا يقفون
على الارجح خلف هجوم سيبراني استهدف
مستشفيات في هولندا ودول اوروبيه اخرى
تدعم اوكرانيا وقال جهاز مكافحه الجرائم
الالكترونيه الهولندي مستشفى في غون جين
شماله هولندا تعطل موقعه الالكتروني جراه
هجوم سبراني فيما اوضح المركز الوطني
الهولندي للامن السيبراني ان اوامر
الهجمات نفذتها على الارجح مجموعه
القراصنه المواليه لروسيا كلنات ضد بلدان
اوروبيه تدعم اوكرانيا
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
ووزيره خارجيه فرنسا كاترين كولونا التي
تزور الرياض بحث اخر المستجدات الاقليميه
والدوليه والجهود المبذوله تجاهها كما
استعرض ولي العهد السعودي والوزير
الفرنسيه العلاقات الثنائيه بين الرياض
وباريس وسبل تعزيزها
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها ليله في حب طلال مداح
اربعون نجما عربيا لتكريم مسيره امتدت 50
عاما
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد افدت وزاره الدفاع
الفلبينيه بان مانيلا وافقت للولايات
المتحده على الوصول الى قواعدها العسكريه
وسط مخاوف متزايده بشان توغل الصين
المتزايد في بحر الصين الجنوبي المتنازع
عليه والتوترات حول تايوان وبحسب الوزاره
سيتم منح واشنطن كذلك حق الوصول الى اربعه
مواقع اخرى في مناطق استراتيجيه من البلاد
وذلك تحت اتفاقيه تعاون دفاعي يعود تاريخه
الى 2014
وقال وزير الدفاع الامريكي استون قال ان
الالتزام ان الالتزام الولايات المتحده
بالدفاع عن الفلبين الصارم مشددا على ان
واشنطن لا تسعى لاقامه قواعد دائمه في
الفلبين بل معالجه الانشطه المزعزعه
للاستقرار اما بخصوص تهديد كوريا الشماليه
افاد اوستن ان هدف امريكا الاول هو زياده
الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه مؤكدا العمل
مع الحلفاء بشكل دائم للتاكد من وجود قوات
ذات مصداقيه في المنطقه
قبل ذلك حذرت كوريا الشماليه حذرت
الولايات المتحده من انها سترد بقوه على
اي تحرك عسكري امريكي في المنطقه مشيره
الى ان رد كوريا الشماليه قد يتضمن
استخدام السلاح النووي واضافت
واشنطن تجاوزت الخطوط الحمر بشده وستزيد
التوتر في المنطقه بتدريباتها العسكريه
[موسيقى]
قال مراسل العربيه ان رشقات رشقات من
الصواريخ اطلقت من قطاع غزه باتجاه
مستوطنات حدوديه مع القطاع اعقبها اطلاق
صافرات الانذار في تلك المستوطنات عقب ذلك
شنت طائرات اسرائيليه غارات على اهداف
داخل القطاع
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال في بيان ان الغارات
استهدفت موقعها انتاج وتخزين مواد خام
كيميائيه تستخدمها حركه حماس بالاضافه الى
استهداف موقع اخر تستخدمه حماس لانتاج
وسائل قتاليه
على الرغم من حصول المقدس اكرم عميره على
ترخيص بناء من بلديه القدس التابعه
لاسرائيل الا انه فوجئ باغلاق القوات
الاسرائيليه مدخل بلدته وهدم منشاته من
دون سابق انذار انتهاك ياتي بعد اصدار
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي اتمار من
غفير قرارا بهدم 14 منزلا ومنشا فلسطينيا
في القدس
اعلى موجودين في هالبلد موجودين وعايشين
فيها وين نروح وين نروح
بدهم يطلعون وين بدنا نروح انولدنا هذا
وعشنا هان وبنشتغل هان
دوافع انتقاميه وعقاب جماعي لتحقيق مكاسب
سياسيه على حساب الحقوق الاساسيه للمدنيين
هكذا يصف الفلسطينيون اصدار تعليمات لهدم
14 منشاه ومنزلا للفلسطينيين والتي تم
تنفيذ سبع منها في حي الطور وسلوان وجبل
المكبر ومناطق اخرى تعتبر حساسه
واستراتيجيه في القدس معيش قرار ما شكيتش
عليك انا دارك فيها رخصه وبدي اهدها
ظهرني بجاهدها خاوي بجاهدها انا جاي اه
مشكل في حكومه اسرائيل ما في عليك تتحجج
السلطات الاسرائيليه بهدم منشات لانها
بدون ترخيص لكن منشاه المقدسي اكرم عميره
تم هدمها على الرغم من حصوله على رخصه
بناء من بلديه القدس التابعه لا
ودفعه رسوم الرخصه باهظه الثمن الا ان
وزاره الداخليه اصدرت قرارا بهدمها حسب
القانون احنا حملنا حالنا ورحنا حسب
القانون وجبنا اللي هو الرخصه هي
الترخيص حسب القانون
وبرضو مساعده ايش وانا ماشي ولما بنيت حسب
القانون اجوا فحصوني لا يقتصر الهدم على
منزل او منشاه فقط بل على احياء كامله
مهدده بالهدم والاخلاء مثل حي بطن الهوى
في سلوان جنوب المسجد الاقصى في القدس
المهدد بالهدم لاستبداله بحدائق توراتيه
لصالح المستوطنين
هنا في قريه سور باهر في القدس تهدم
القوات الاسرائيليه منشاه لفلسطين قيد
الانشاء بعد اوامر وزير الامن القومي
المتشدد اعتمر بن جبير بهدم اربعه عشر
منزلا للفلسطينيين في القدس على الرغم من
المحاولات العربيه والامريكيه بالتهدئه
لان كلاسي من القدس العربيه
في تظاهرات فنيه سعوديه خليجيه عربيه كبرى
شارك اكثر من اربعين فنانا وفنانه في
تكريم الفنان السعودي الراحل طلال المداح
وذلك على مسرح محمد عبده ارينا في الرياض
ضمن ليله صوت الارض بمبادره من رئيس هيئه
الترفيه في السعوديه تركي ال الشيخ نتابع
[موسيقى]
اكثر من 40 فنانا من 13 دوله عربيه صعدوا
على المسرح في ليله واحده تكريما للفنان
السعودي طلال مداح الذي رحل قبل اكثر من
22 عاما وبعد اكثر من نصف قرن من عطائه
الفني لا يزال راسخا في ذاكره عشاقه في
السعوديه وعموم العالم العربي المهمه
السعودي اذا جينا نؤرخ للفن للغناء بالذات
والغناء جزء مهم من الفن يعني فلؤرح من
عند طلال مداح
[موسيقى]
ليله صوت الارض الحدث الفني الاضخم عربيا
وعالميا اقيمت في الرياض برعايه هيئه
الترفيه السعوديه بحضور الالاف من
الجماهير التي ما زالت تردد اغنيات الراحل
حتى يومنا هذا ومن مختلف الاعمار
سلمت عليه قلت لها ترجيع الشيخ فطاربي
واتحادي فكان يحسبني ولد عبد المحسن الشيخ
الداعم الاتحاد طلعنا غلبان وقال يضحك
وحضني اسمحوا لي اغني اغنيه بالعود بهذا
العود اللي احتفظت ابو 22 سنه وهو الاستاذ
طلال
ما اقول
وقد
فيك
حنيني هذه الليله جاءت بعد مبادره رئيس
الهيئه السعوديه للترفيه تركي ال الشيخ
الذي قدم قبل اسابيع دعوه مفتوحه لكل نجوم
السعوديه والخليج والعالم العربي للمشاركه
وهو ما قبل باستجابه اكبر عدد من الفنانين
والفنانات سعوديا وخليجيا وعربيا انتم
ابناء فنان عظيم من حقكم انكم ترفعون
راسكم في بلدكم اليوم في تكريم ابوكم
يا عمر
شافوني مشغل طلال مداح
فكلن يطلع من عندي ما حد يكلمني يعني اكون
ثاني
[موسيقى]
نشاهد معكم مشاهدينا عرض عسكري في مدينه
فولكراد بمناسبه الذكرى الثمانين للانتصار
السوفيتي على القوات الالمانيه في معركه
اشترنغاد اذا هذا الاحتفال في روسيا الان
بمناسبه مرور 80 عاما لانتصار القوات
المسلحه السوفييتيه في معركه
بصفتها طبعا هذه المعركه نقطه انعطاف في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه ومن المتوقع ان
يشارك الرئيس الروسي هذا الاحتفال وان
يلقي ايضا كلمه خلال العرض الذي ياتي في
وقت تشهد فيه موسكو كما نعلم صراعا كبيرا
مع الغرب في معركتها على اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
ختام النشره في امان الله